hello everyone and welcome back to
Rotten Tomatoes is wrong on a very
special day for a very special movie
with a very special guest and my
incredibly special co-host Jacqueline
Coley Jacqueline you're here we are back
and the question Remains the Same what
did you have for breakfast this morning
as always it was a big heaping glass of
air because I just don't know nothing
you do nothing water
I mean that's good I think you're
supposed to drink water like 30 minutes
before you do anything else that you
take in because it's like better for I
don't know you know we're we're talking
about cereals and how they are really
forming our minds as far as how
important breakfast is but I still do it
every day no milk just Dry Cereal yeah I
mean you fell for the propaganda but
that's not a bad thing every day
honestly breakfast is not the propaganda
as much as orange juice orange juice is
the devil's cocktail I'm sorry I don't
like it California people you can come
for me if you feel I'm a great girl
they're gonna come for you no grapefruit
juice a mimosa is better with anything
besides orange juice all right well at
least we can all agree on this is that
if you have to have a meal the most
important meal of your day is Pizza The
Hut or just Pizza in general Pizza is
always the best meal of the day and I
consider this movie to be the pizza the
Hutt of films not just because it
actually Stars a character named Pizza
the Hutt in one of the all-time great
visual gags it's also just because it's
funny it's important it is a Cornerstone
of my childhood and I hope a lot of
other people listening right now it's
the 1987 Mel Brooks directed classic
Spaceballs the parody of Star Wars and
space operas and a lot of other science
fiction and nonsense thrown in there
this movie seems divisive these days and
I have no idea why and the Tomato Meter
is a prime culprit of why Spaceballs is
for some reason lost on today's youth
it's our job to get them back because
it's currently 56 percent on the Tomato
Meter which is a crime against humanity
83 percent of the audience score so
that's pretty good way to go audience
the Critics on the other hand I'm not
sure what they were thinking but that's
why we have special guests and that's
why we bring in uh somebody who we love
when they come in and pinch hit for us
they always deliver clever insights they
always deliver well thought out
diatribes and with a dash of funny in
there and a little bit of tacos
sometimes Juan Harris is our you know
him from everything from screen junkies
he's a he's a schmodown combatant of
lore and he's a very talented writer and
an amazing fellow on social media Juan
Harris welcome wow what an intro thank
you Mark geez I'm glowing
well never never has a man received such
a such a a lovely and thought out uh
introduction well you know here's the
thing about me and Jacqueline can attest
to this I tend to lean more towards the
nice intros when I think I think the
guest is going to be like-minded with me
on the Tomato Meter especially about a
movie is controversial I mean it's right
smack dab in the middle it's fresh
adjacent but it's not so I gotta ask you
Spaceballs
is it wrong on a Tomato Meter uh a
hundred percent for this move and I know
that that's not how Rotten Tomatoes
works it's not it's not the quality it
is not reflected in the number that's
the number of critics I understand but
in my heart this is a hundred percent
fresh this is it's one of my favorite
comedies but largely because I saw it at
age eight with uh my dad and my my
family and we we loved it I watched it
obsessively over and over again as a kid
I still have several of these sequences
memorized so yeah this is a beloved film
for me uh I quote it still probably more
frequently than an adult should uh so
yeah I I'm I'm with you 100 of us oh
wand you did such a good job defending
your point already but you fell into
that trap the Jacqueline laid for you
because you quoted the exact age that
you saw at the first time that Jack and
I got into a bar fight over not two
weeks ago talking about how everybody
when they saw it when they were a kid
loved it so Jaclyn Lon saw it when he
was eight and loved it I probably saw
when I was eight loved it Jacqueline
Coley is Rotten Tomatoes right or wrong
when I was eight they were so wrong oh
no at 40. kind of right I'm sorry look
okay abstractly I love love love
Spaceballs but this is not like a
question with other movies where I'm
like I feel like the score is wrong
it's really a great long SNL bit and if
it was done by anybody else besides Mel
Brooks I would call it amazing
but this man gave me history of the
World Part One this man gave me Young
Frankenstein this this young man gave me
Blazing Saddles and the producers and
this young man is pushing a hundred so
I'm saying something by calling him a
young man but this is Mel Brooks
and as a Mel Brooks fan as a Mel Brooks
stand it is bottom tier and I'm sorry to
say that I am here so much Amel Brooks
fan that even I know I feel like in his
parody goddess or parody god-esque way
he's kind of folded in on Spaceballs in
so many ways because it's not a really
accurate parody of Star Wars or space
operas or anything else it's just a fun
story where he put those skins on top of
it y'all I I have some fun with this and
I I also I I think you're making some
good points here and so we're gonna get
into this we're also going to get into
like our favorite Mel Brooks movie and
where Spaceballs might rank
um but before we get into all that Jack
one I'm so jealous of you right now
because you get to give us a quick
synopsis as to what Spaceballs is about
you told us what it's not about so what
is baseball's about obviously we know
that Spaceballs is a parody of All Space
movies and operas but in this one in
particular We are following a more
comedic side of it and we are led by
Bill Pullman who plays our I guess
lovable Rogue Lone Star this is the Han
Solo character and he has been tasked to
bring back the Wayward Princess Vespa
who has decided that she does not want
to marry her prince charming a very
sleepy one at that but she does not want
to marry him and so she bonds and then
she is then kidnapped by the evil empire
because they're trying to steal the
oxygen rights of her planet and they
literally are trying to steal it because
Mel Brooks who is president Snoop uh I
don't even know how to say I'm like
saying it wrong truth I'm gonna call him
it's the letters of Brooks mixed up yeah
yeah scrupe uh president's group and he
is going to be trying to essentially
steal these air rights and so this is
the adventure to get the captured
Princess to bring back the air rights so
that they can make sure that the planet
does not get destroyed and then we get a
maybe a lost Prince story we learn about
the Schwartz which is their version of
the force we meet yogurt who's
essentially Yoda and we have a grand old
time and Joan Rivers has probably one of
the greatest voice performances ever as
her version of R2D2 with her virgin
alert wow look at that what a great just
a nice encapsulation of everything that
this movie really is about we're just
trying to save some air from planet
druidia so we're going to talk a lot
about Spaceballs and I cannot wait to
dive into this episode with you all
because this has been a requested movie
too so thanks to all of our fans who are
telling us you need to cover Spaceballs
forever we're finally doing it for y'all
and right now we turn it over to our
good friend Tim Ryan who's our expert
review curation manager here at Rotten
Tomatoes he's going to tell us what the
critics were saying at the time of
Spaceballs this release back in 1987.
Tim I hope some of them were eight years
old
moments with Tim my wife and I were at
the movies a few years ago when who do
we see walking into the theater right
behind us but Bill Pullman look my wife
said to me it's Lone Star and Mr Pullman
heard her and he cracked a wry smile I
was 10 when Spaceballs was released and
my favorite movie was Star Wars so I was
the exact demographic for Mel Brooks's
send-up of big budget sci-fi I also
hadn't seen alien yet so that final
scene soared over my head but I laughed
anyway and I know there were Millions
more just like me but for a lot of
grown-ups and certainly a lot of
grown-up movie critics Spaceballs was
something of a disappointment a lot of
them felt it was a low brow satire that
had some decent gags but lacked the wit
and incisiveness of the likes of The
Producers or Blazing Saddles or Young
Frankenstein Spaceballs is rotten at 56
on the Tomato Meter with 45 reviews but
it does have an 83 audience score so
what did the critics have to say back in
1987 in a fresh review Kathy Burke of
United Press International wrote this
stand up by by director Mel Brooks
incorporates the silliest aspects of all
the major Space Adventures of the last
decade and the whole is a hilarious
combination of its parts
however in a rotten review Richard
schickel of Time Magazine wrote The Crew
flanks itself energetically through
space in search of laughs but it will
never penetrate the Galaxy where Blazing
Saddles and Young Frankenstein traced
their giddy orbits the Rotten Tomatoes
critics consensus reads there's fine
spoofery and amusing characters in
Spaceballs though it's a far cry from
Mel Brooks's Peak era so that's
Spaceballs Jacqueline Mark May the
Schwartz be with you and also with you
Tim thank you so much and so Wes we go
right to our merchandising point of the
podcast let's go right into movie talk
[Music]
I want to talk about this movie Just In
in context what Jaclyn sort of opened up
in that can of worms where we are
looking at this not just as a standalone
film but as part of Mel Brooks's
hilarious and amazing Canon so Lon
Harris do you have an easy answer as to
where Spaceballs might rank for you as
far as Mel Brooks directed movies go I
mean it's it's very tough I think there
are some there are some obvious Stone
Cold Classics in this filmography and I
noticed like a lot of people keep going
back to like you're you're obviously
comparing it to Blazing Saddles you're
obviously comparing it to Young
Frankenstein legendary iconic movies
that inform what we think of as as
parody I will say I think Spaceballs
fits right alongside those in terms of
maybe not moment to moment joke to joke
like I I'm not gonna say it's as
consistently funny maybe as like a
Blazing Saddles but I will say I think
that what Mel Brooks does so well in all
of his parodies including Spaceballs is
they really do feel like the movies
they're parodying it doesn't feel like
it's just a throwaway like and this is
not to knock these Zucker Abrams guys or
anyone else that came along but a lot of
the time the idea is it's a parody it
can feel loose it can feel more like a
comedy it doesn't have to feel like it
is actually one of the movies from the
genre it's parodying but if you think
about Young Frankenstein he really makes
it feel like a classic Universal horror
movie he shoots it that way he uses the
Frankenstein set elements it really you
know it evokes that era and I think same
with Spaceballs he actually worked with
Lucas and Industrial like magic he made
a deal with Lucas we won't merchandise
the movie let us use some of the sets in
industrial Light and magic and so it
does evoke Star Wars in a way that I
think is beyond what you would probably
expect from a Mel Brooks movie and I
think that works really well it feels
like one of these kinds of stories even
as it's being really zany yeah and
Jacqueline I I do take your points of
heart where I feel like Young
Frankenstein and Blazing Saddles like
Juan said are sort of the Two Goats of
Mel Brooks's filmography and I would put
this on a part just below them with a
history of the World Part One with a
silent movie which I think is an
underrated classic and so anxiety too I
think I was just about to say high
anxiety yeah right way worse than high
anxiety high anxiety took those
psychological thrillers and understood
them again sorry go ahead Mark I know I
I I think we're all kind of making the
same point here in that once the 80s hit
and once I think Mel Brooks first of all
looked at the Zucker Abram Zucker movies
like airplane and top secret and then
you also have this new generation of
kids that are watching MTV I don't think
that played a small part in the way that
Mel Brooks directed movies because if
you look at something like Spaceballs or
you look at something like Robin Hood
Men in Tights which some people love
some people are about met on Dracula
dead and Loving It all of those movies
starting with Spaceballs I feel like had
more jokes crammed into them than Young
Frankenstein and Blazing Saddles but I
feel like every joke in Blazing Saddles
and Young Frankenstein is a home run and
I feel like starting with Spaceballs
some of those jokes are home runs some
of them are just singles some of them
are just we're just getting on base so
not everything is a gut Buster like you
would see in Young Frankenstein but
there's moments in this movie that just
murder me and I want to talk about some
of those but I I think we're all in
agreement here Jacqueline that the 70s
Mel Brooks is sort of the gold standard
when it comes to spoof movies
absolutely and the other thing who I
will say
criticize it as
this look later years Mel Brooks Men in
Tights definitely was not a spoof that
had a great critical reception but I
felt it lived in what it was better than
what Spaceballs was again for everything
about Spaceballs that felt so much of
what it was and therefore understood
what it was I don't know if this was as
timely as it could have been to really
spew it the other thing about Blazing
Saddles is it was contemporary with the
actual Western sort of I would say peak
in a lot of ways so you had people
looking at Blazing Saddles along the
last sort of Bastion of the grand
American John Wayne western industry of
movies that was going on at the time and
so it felt so close to it meanwhile
having a such a commercial Star Wars
parody that really talked about the
industries obsession with Star Wars more
than it actually talked about the events
of anything that you wanted to parody
within Star Wars is my problem like I
feel like the parody in Star Wars is
just not an interesting parody because
it's really just spoofing it's really
taking politics in the movie industry
and putting it under the skin of a space
movie and having that be what it's
really parroting it's not really
parroting in my opinion
Star Wars and so there's a little weak I
think it takes a lot more liberties with
the characterizations because Lone Star
is kind of Han Solo and Luke Skywalker
sort of wrapped into one you know
exactly and the antithesis of that is
the problem that means that they really
didn't understand why those two
characters were separate and by putting
them together they kind of set up the
character to fail yeah but we're also
spoofing an entire Trilogy Where we just
want to have some laughs with one movie
here a lot you can do that Family Guy
did it very well and it's not a one to
one I mean I think that's the other
thing I would say is it's not just this
is Mel Brooks's Star Wars parody it's a
parody of the whole genre and a lot of
70s and 80s sci-fi and we do get alien
we do get Star Trek we do get Planet of
the Apes where there's a lot of it's
sort of Mel Brooks's attempt to like
take on the entire sci-fi Space Opera
fantasy in space kind of idea and I
think it works pretty well the one other
thing I was going to say in its defense
is uh a lot of the classic Mel Brooks
movies are his original cast of
collaborators that he worked with all
the time you're and Dom DeLuise is in
this he's Pizza The Hut but and Cloris
Leachman of course is you know we we uh
but yeah like the the Cloris Leachman
Harvey Corman all those people that were
Gene Wilder that were filling in those
original films this is him working with
you know the Next Generation people who
grew up watching his original stuff and
I think he equates himself really well
and gets some classic performances we've
mentioned Bill Pullman John Candy Rick
Moranis like a lot of the great comic
sort of voices of that that era he
managed to kind of bring to the
Forefront and give them Fun Classic
roles to play as well no the thing that
I always go back to is that I find
Spaceballs to be enjoyable and I like a
lot of the jokes when we're following
the adventures of Bill Pullman uh his
character Lone Star and barf and and
Daphne zuniga's princess Fest but all
that good stuff however the Imp Imperial
stuff the Empire stuff everything with
dark helmet and Colonel Sanders kills me
I am on the floor howling when I'm
watching the evil parts of this movie
because there is just an unmitigated
genius at work who thinks who am I going
to cast to play my big bad Darth Vader
Rick Moranis the funny short guy I'm
gonna put him being overwhelmed
constantly in this giant suit the Dark
Helmet suit has a tie it's a tie and
it's just all those little kind of gags
and I'll tell you right now my favorite
gag in this entire movie as of today my
favorite visual gag is when we're
searching for Our Heroes the the Empire
searching for Our Heroes and they're on
the desert planet and so Dark Helmet has
his khaki Safari Dark Helmet suit it is
because he's got shorts on and he's got
like the Khaki colored helmet instead it
is an amazing visual gag I've sent the
troopsana head to Vector 78 sir good
let's get moving yes sir driver prepare
to move out what do what are you
preparing you're always preparing just
go let's go yes sir sir shouldn't you
sit down and Mark but and this is
producy Lucy here hi Lucy it's not just
a tie it's a it's a penis did you notice
that it doesn't that's too little yeah
there's two little epaulettes like right
here next to the time
oh yeah I mean that's also worth doing
oh it is a movie that if you only
watched it as a child it really does
reward going back at least once as an
adult because there are a lot of jokes
that I promise you went right over your
head when you were a kid I also uh uh I
did not get the alien I I saw this
before I saw alien so I didn't get the
presence of John heard uh showing up in
that scene either but yeah there's a lot
of just like dirty jokes and borsche
belt kind of material that was flying
right over eight-year-old me's head when
I first saw it yeah including the the
penis tie look and I don't want to like
hate on this I love Spaceballs so much I
just don't think like when I look back
on it I like you know like I went back
this weekend and I like you know watched
the first hour watch you know a few key
scenes and I'm like yeah because I've
seen it like Lon said oh at least 50
times probably more like definitely I'm
your father's brother's nephew's cousins
former former roommate yeah thank you so
I've definitely got this but it's it's
just I don't know how to put it it
wasn't all it didn't it wasn't all jelly
it didn't all like like hit me in the
right places but I will agree with you
mark anytime they're in the whites what
I like to call space void of the like
deck like the halideck area like you
know that I'm with you it is it is all
good and I do love like the Lone Star
barf storyline and everything that they
do together but it just doesn't make a
whole movie and I think what you said
Lon is true they tried to parody too
much in this movie and that's why it
doesn't work for me they did bite off a
lot and so I I wanted I want to go go to
Juan first on this one Juan who's the
character because I'll take Dark Helmet
which you're welcome to draft as well
who's the character that you find
yourself following for the jokes that
you find yourself following for the
story if you want to who's your favorite
character out of Spaceballs I mean I
think yeah definitely as a kid I was a
huge Rick Moranis fan even before this
like he was already one of my favorite
presences in a movie so that was a big
part of the reason I even wanted to see
this I don't even think I necessarily
would have known Mel Brooks at this
point it was really Rick Moranis so so
dark helmet for sure but also I would
have to say yeah barf I think is like
like a Cornerstone character for me uh
and and you know John Candy managed to
find ways to make these characters who
were gross and the jokes were raunchy
and crass but it's it's so lovable
there's this warm Humanity Underneath It
All even though he's playing this
ridiculous MOG half man half dog
character uh that that candy could
always find and I think he's he's like
the the emotional center of the movie if
you will the line that he has that that
flew over my head most of the time as a
kid so I needed to watch this 50 times
to really like find that line and
realize how funny it is is towards the
end when Lone Star is going to leave his
ship the Winnebago so he can sneak in
and go confront Dark Helmet and so he
says I'm going in there and barf says
he's going in there and there
I wouldn't it's just a pause like what's
he doing uh Jacqueline you're you
mentioned you also love Joan Rivers in
this movie so who is the character that
that Jacqueline Coley gloms on to oh
absolutely Joan like first of all I was
somebody that watched Fashion Police
before we realized how cringe it was
like I love Joan Rivers one of the
reasons why I love hacks and signed up
for it before I even knew who was
involved was because it was about her
and that is such a great voice
performance and like I really want to
key into this one she was the perfect
thing to have like this version of a
princess have that be her absolute sort
of like like she's literally playing
like a gentle type you know the Jewish
like I gotta fuss over you here and fuss
over you there because we're trying to
get you married off and the Virgin alert
The Comedy of that that is probably one
of my favorite laughs no Mister you stay
over there the virginal word is an
all-time dad in this what's the joke
though that like was there a joke that
you saw when you were a kid Jacqueline
and you're like that's the funniest
thing in this movie and then you grow up
and you're like no no now this is the
funniest thing honestly as a kid it was
getting jammed because I thought that
getting jammed was really Jam I really
did like I I was like is that what it
means no man would dare give me the
raspberry uh yeah I really did think
that jamming was jam and it was so funny
because I had a family member at the
time that was on a sub and I was like
asking them as like is that how they
like lose y'all and he was like no
I was so serious because when you do SUB
Duty people don't tell you this about
sub Duty um there's like points where
like they're just not in communication
like they're just kind of like gone and
you can't talk to them you can't get
anything to them like they obviously I
guess the the military knows kind of
where they are but you can't talk to
them they have to like surface for them
to get messages and all that and so I
was like is that what happens when you
can't talk on the sub for three days
he's like no that means that there's a
Russian Warhead or something it's not
actual preserves yeah so am I crazy or
does Pizza The Hut actually look
delicious yeah no it's a it's a it's a
weirdly appetizing uh because they made
the cheese like realistically droopy and
the pepperonis are falling off just like
a nice hot cheese pizza it looks like
melting cheese it's funny too that his
the guy who's with Pizza The Hut his
sort of spokesman is is a Max Edge room
parody which is what I was just about to
say it goes back to our they're trying
to take on like everything sci-fi in the
1980s whether it was in outer space or
not even you guys he looks like a
pustule he looks like a gross like zit
thing that's just leaking and he looked
like he liked to eat them because so I'm
not gonna lie to you it's sort of like
once you see the video of the idiot
eating Tide Pods you want to eat it it's
not like you think that it tastes good
but they looked like they were having
such a fun time doing it the other thing
I'll add about the Max Headroom guys
that's what I will get to on Spaceballs
they weren't just parroting Sci-Fi
Action genre all of that space stuff
they were also parroting the MTV
generation and they were parading this
very commercialistic approach to both
filmmaking and movie consumption that
was being sort of like epitomized in the
80s with movies like die hard and things
like that and this movie really I think
keyed in on that early too with a lot of
the merchandising stuff and like the
Empire looked more like Studio systems
at the time this is back when you know
people like you know katzenberg and this
is the Donnie Simpson early Jerry
Bruckheimer days where apparently if you
read the books those guys were just high
on cocaine and Big Ideas they didn't
have anything going on
I mean there's a there's a great
sequence that I think touches on exactly
this that uh I think also it feels more
modern than a lot of late 80s comedy
which is when they get the video
cassette of Spaceballs the movie and
watch it during the movie which is this
weird it's like a very post-post modern
like yes contemporary meta sort of joke
like you could almost imagine like Space
Jam a new Legacy or something having
that scene of like let's stop the movie
and like fast forward and find out what
we're supposed to do next and I really
feel like yeah Mel Brooks was like a
like a decade ahead with that stuff yeah
a decade ahead because I think he was
frustrated one thing I will know
studying directors of his ilk at a
certain time it's like when you look at
um uh John uh Hudson towards the end of
his career Billy wild towards the end of
his career they get very I would say
disillusioned with uh the system and I
feel like this was his I'm disillusioned
with the system movie and I will also
give a big shout out who just to a
character who does not get their do as
far as their comedic value in this film
and that is George Weiner's performance
as Colonel Sanders who is sort of the
right hand of Dark Helmet and one of my
favorite sequences I I love just how
dark helmet is this big bad but then as
soon as he just lifts his faceplate up
he's just this weak little kid who and
and the scene where Colonel Sanders
walks in on Dark Helmet playing with his
toys and you get to see just who really
any Evil Genius is at heart where they
just want to be loved they just want to
get the girl at the end of the day and
so he walks in on him playing with his
dolls and he says no sir I didn't see
you playing with your dolls again oh
leave me alone no kiss me no no yes no
no yes no yes oh
oh oh your helmet is so big
you need it on the bridge sir knock on
my door knock next time yes sir
did you see anything no sir I didn't see
you playing with your dolls again good
and then you also have another sequence
where they feel like they've captured
the Princess Vespa and it's basically
Dark Helmet talking trash about her to
her thinking she's in the car and when
she's not his first reaction is to open
his face plate and just whine she's not
in there and it just works so well as
the toughest bad guy in the Galaxy
suddenly becoming the weakest person on
the ship I I cannot get enough of that
juxta position I I do think there are a
lot of gags that do kind of Express what
we're what we're sort of saying which is
just like the exhaustion of making
movies in the late 80s as opposed to
when he first started making movies and
it was more like get a bunch of funny
people together and kind of figure it
out what you're gonna do uh like
sequence is like the endless special
effect of the ship where it never it's
just this model that you're never
through with that it just keeps going
and going or uh the you've captured
their stunt doubles sequence where it's
like all these action scenes and it's
not even your actors it's like some guy
with a mustache looking at stogie
pretending to be a Princess Vespa and
there is a lot of that kind of material
in it of just like movies used to be
about stories and characters and jokes
and now they're about visual effects and
budgets and these like huge epic
sprawling tentpole ideas this was a
turning point though I feel like for
spoof films in general because once we
got into this came out 1987
once we got into the 90s and then even
going through like the scary movie era
which I know a lot of people appreciate
then you had another Not Another Teen
Movie and it seemed like it wasn't about
the story at all it became about a loose
premise like oh we're gonna make this
about horror movies and then we're just
gonna put a bunch of Pop Culture
references in here there's some pop
culture references like we talked about
pizza the Huts the second in command is
just like Max Headroom from the 1980s
from those Coke commercials but I wonder
if there's something to that because
I've never felt like a spoof movie has
made me laugh if I saw it for the first
time as an adult and I can't
differentiate if that's because I am too
old to enjoy it where spoof movies have
to get you when you're a kid so that
you'll love them forever or if spoof
movies just aren't as good as they used
to be Juan Harris any insight on that I
mean I'm trying to think I definitely
don't like spoof movies as much as I
once did but there's definitely like I
think there are films that at least are
circling that Jean genre that I would
still enjoy I mean I would think uh
Black Dynamite is the first one that
pops into my head is like an obvious
Counterpoint like I was a grown man when
I watched black dynamite and I love that
movie I think it's hilarious but I think
even like to kind of go back to the meta
Point like stuff like the Chippendales
Rescue Rangers movie this year like we
don't maybe think of it as a spoof movie
specifically because it's not like it's
like you know it's not like what Hot
Shots is doing to Top Gun where it's
like a one to one but it is a spoof of
all of those like James Mars didn't has
to go on a road trip with Sonic the
Hedgehog type movies like it is kind of
riffing on that whole idea of like the
hybrid animation live action stuff so
you know I mean I I think it's still
it's still viable even if it's not maybe
I don't love it the way I did when Naked
Gun was still an active property that's
a great point you make Jacqueline do you
feel like spoof movies are just better
suited for kids and then once you grow
up it's like Never Never Land you just
can't go back no yes no look I do feel
like there's always this thing with like
when you see something is your page full
it's this idea of like when you're a kid
your page is empty and anything that you
find the minute you find Star Wars it
can take up the whole page as you get to
be like 40 plus there's a lot of things
already on the page nothing is coming
that's going to rival the Washington
Redskins on your page Mark so I would
say that with parodies
after a certain point especially if
you're looking at Mel Brooks's
filmography what's left on the page to
top that I just think parody has a
different place now it is less about
this and it is more about parroting I
think themes of stuff like I look at
boys as a great parody you just don't
know that it's a parody that's a great
call too Starship Troopers is a parody
and so it's not that parodies have
changed they're just it's like horror
you're gonna have to subvert the
expectations of what's being parodied
because what's considered shocking moves
with every generation and this
generation I'm just because I remember
we did a review like a classic review of
Spaceballs for schmoes and like a lot of
the the responses like the comments we
got were I'm just you know I was born in
1995 or whatever and like I just I go
back and I watch this movie it just
doesn't really hit me the same way and
and in my elitist brain because I was
born in 1980 I'm like how could you not
how could you not get it but I I
understand some times it is just tough
to go back and put yourself in that time
capsule but because we were all somewhat
alive and and we're cognizant around the
time that Spaceballs came out maybe it
is just something that our childhood
like just picked up it is never let go I
do wonder what it was like to be a
Critic at that time though who because
that's really the confounding thing to
me is is that critics of the time saw it
and didn't think it was it was funny
maybe they just didn't think it lived up
to the other Mel Brooks movies of the
70s Jaclyn maybe that's that's to your
point up top yeah I mean it's not even
so much that it didn't live up because I
would say you can't look at Men in
Tights and say that in any way compares
to brazing saddle but I do found that he
found ways to be inventive with his
collaborators at that point inventive
with maybe this types of stuff he was
doing before later when he you know sort
of semi-retired but even like doing the
producers on Broadway he was very
involved in that revamp and then the
producers uh uh the the movie adaptation
so I just feel like he had his moments
in in the sun he still could have more
moments because if folks don't know
history of the World Part Two the series
is coming
40 years in the making uh but I would
just say like again I think he's doing
it on television which is going to help
and hopefully he takes he looks at
things like the boys he looks at things
like Starship Troopers he looks at
things like Veep and and the thick of it
and makes a balance a little bit
differently between you know again the
parody and and the reality I do think
you can still find humor and fun and and
comedy and parody as an adult it just
can't be kid jokes most parodies are kid
jokes look we it's lampshade jokes it's
like look this is Luke Skywalker but we
made him funny
I mean I think we also did like there
there was this and I don't want to beat
up I don't even remember Fryeburg and
one other name Seltzer or whatever there
there were the like the the scary movie
Epic movie Date Movie Guys and that I
feel like gave kind of the genre a bad
name and it was very much the lazy kind
of jokes where it's like just have
jigsaw show up like what are you doing
here jigsaw you're not in this scene and
uh it where it's like references instead
of jokes and I think it kind of gave the
spoof movie A Bad Name yeah and I don't
know I was just gonna say now I feel
like a lot of those kinds of jokes and a
lot of the the parody spoof ideas still
exists I mean the scream franchise is
like the biggest thing in horror it's
just they're baked into the other movies
they're not Standalone this movie only
exists to be a spoof yeah the only thing
I was gonna add to that is I will not
take any shade on kidney Ivory Reigns
and scary movie but anything that was
like past that
yeah like the second tier versions where
it was like Sparta movies or like Meet
the Spartans I believe Mr Spartans was
the one for me where I think I was able
to pinpoint why I don't like these kind
of movies anymore is because I I think I
said at the time it was like US Weekly
made a movie where like meet the
Spartans there's no good reason why
there should be a Britney Spears's bald
joke in a movie called Meet the Spartans
when you're parodying 300 but it's there
and it's like what are we even doing
with this stuff anymore I will give love
to the scary movie franchise though
simply because of the the bloodline that
they come from with I'm gonna get you
sucking a classic and uh yeah don't uh
don't be a menace on the streets of
South Central While Drinking Your
Children yeah yeah and but this is the
thing comparison my dogma's like that
too though Kevin Smith actually has a
lot of spoof DNA as well I mean it's
just basically a skewing of religion in
general and then there's a story we're
following but the Buddy Jesus from Dogma
seems like something that you could have
put into outer space and Spaceballs I
have one quick interjection here because
you brought up like the 90s kid because
I had this experience Mark so like Lon
like all of you I saw it as soon as I
could I was born in 90 and then I
probably saw it like eight years later
so I was probably also eight years old
because this is my dad's religion you
know he's our number again yeah there we
go and um so I saw it later this was a
movie that we watched I don't know 17
times a year it was naughty so I gotta
like it was one of those movies where I
had to kind of sneak away from my mom
but like my dad and I would watch it
loved it so much watched it for the
first time and like I don't know 20
something years last night and the
experience was interesting because well
first off Jacqueline to your point my
husband was like this is like a long SNL
skit he did not like it and for me it
changed it was no longer this like
magical naughty sort of forbidden fruit
sort of movie to watch but I still loved
it and the jokes that I was laughing at
were not the jokes I was laughing at
then I was telling you guys beforehand
the joke one of the jokes that made me
laugh out loud I don't even know if it's
that funny is when Bill Pullman's in the
desert and they've crash landed to get
away from the the Empire so to speak and
he's pissed off about the giant hair
dryer yeah and he's like industrial
strength hair dryer
and he's like you're
ugly when you're angry
I got that joke so it's just this I'm
I'm gonna show it to my kids I I still
love it I do think it's a little bit
slow for my 2022 80d brain because I'm
so used to that kind of quick fast
humors and it just felt kind of slow but
I still love it it's just different now
in the end the the end still works on a
different level for me because I've
never seen Planet of the Apes before I
saw Spaceballs and so I just thought it
was funny that the thing turned the ship
turned into like a Statue of Liberty
almost kind of knock off and it crash
lands and it I think it's a it turns
into a giant space made and then it
crashed like she's vacuuming up the
oxygen from yeah and then and they're
only in the head because like it's like
they don't will get out and so they're
just like
yeah that was that's a great countdown
again there's so many great movies in
this I feel like I'm gonna be like the
bad person that's down on it I'm not I
just I understand like I get why this
wasn't well received at the time I get
why it hasn't necessarily risen up in
people's estimation I think people like
Spaceballs but is this a movie that
people are like this is an injustice I
mean you have to be in an age if you're
in an age range if you're born between
like 77 and 82 you're like this is an
outrage and I think everybody else like
accepts that it was just a comedy but
here's the thing it's and it goes back
to like the conversation we always have
around the Oscars where we especially
Comics don't feel like they reward
comedies enough but the critics have
really warmed up to the jackass movies
over time jackass forever is fresh and I
feel like critics are finally like fresh
certified fresh so I feel like the
critics are finally like hey um what is
jackass trying to do and did it succeed
at it and the answer is yes I just feel
like what is Spaceballs trying to do is
it trying to tell you a coherent story
no it's just Mel Brooks is just he's
he's a comedian he's just trying to make
you laugh hard every 15 seconds that's
his only goal and I feel like Spaceballs
achieved that and so much like our
podcast helped influence Sister Act 2 to
get that up the Tomato Meter to
prominence my goal for this entire show
has always been just get Spaceballs into
fresh territories up to 59 at one point
it's down to 56 come on critics I know
you're out there see Spaceballs review
it and maybe hopefully you'll feel more
like Juan and I than Jacqueline although
it seems like Jaclyn and producing Lucy
enjoyed this movie our engineer Brian
Perez I have different thoughts about
him so
um last thing here before we go to
mailbag is I have a Spaceballs trivia
question that I and only I can ask and
don't get your hopes up because you're
probably going to be disappointed is
everybody ready I'm ready it's got a
great soundtrack right we hear Bon
Jovi's raise your hands when we meet the
Winnebago for the first time sure can
anybody name the Van Halen song very
briefly used in Spaceballs can you at
least tell me like when in the movie it
happened I will tell you exactly when it
happens thanks for asking Jackson it's
got the two women in the bed right
president scroob is in bed and he
somebody calls in on the on the wall
isn't that the sitting or am I right
it's not that scene
God hurt alien scene it's when they walk
into the diner when Lone Star and barf
walk into that space Diner you hear the
whales of Sammy Hagar and his very first
Van Halen's song on the very first Van
Halen did say hello baby it's all right
yeah it's Ryland just entered her mind
Palace the song is get up I do remember
the lean back and see if I can Google
this real quick without Mark noticing
you hear the Riff the guitar note and
then it's Cuts you're right and then we
go into this a hard rock song that plays
at the other scene I'm thinking of I
just can't it's like Motley Crue or
something there is yeah there certainly
is President's group um you know he's
like a lot of politicians he really
enjoys that dude he's like I told you
never to call me on this wall this is an
unlisted wall my brother and I still say
that to each other yeah that's what
the name five but barely five I bet you
can't I think you I mean well it's gonna
affect our friendship if you don't at
least try right now okay Hot for Teacher
yes jump nailed it Panama you're
crushing 1984.
here we go wait wait wait wait this is
where it gets difficult hold on um I got
one I got one uh right now thank you
thank you
I know you I know you can get it yeah
there's there's a few more come on Van
Halen who does Van Halen like to like to
jog with in the morning
[Laughter]
or run with
sneakers
done the uh impossible and she's named
five Van Halen songs and a friendship
and a podcast co-hosting relationship
has been restored right once the problem
is I was gonna name all of the songs of
the people the solo artist so I was like
California girls
um
the the helium's falling out of the
balloon now but I got it I got five I
got to five I got to five
[Music]
foreign
professional that Brian Perez is he's
like I'm going to wait until these
morons shut up but then he's just like
you know what this is good a time as any
just go ahead and hit this because he
knows if you were talking about Van
Halen it could last six hours you are
not gonna be the one to turn that faucet
off he has had to deal with that more
times than he'd like to remember so we
can always accept emails why because we
have an email address it's RT is wrong
at
rottentomatoes.com email us anytime with
your thoughts with what movies you want
us to be talking about we'll throw some
TV shows in there as well books uh maybe
a different podcast so Michael Galvin
Ali writes us and he's a fresh member of
the ketchup crew says hi Rotten Tomatoes
please review Batman Forever from 1995.
the movie was fun and campy Jim Carrey's
portrayal as the Riddler it was funny
Val kummer did a good job playing Batman
and Chris O'Donnell as Dick Grayson and
Robin didn't disappoint I could care
less about Tommy Lee Jones as Two-Face
and Nicole Kidman is Dr Chase Meridian
as Batman love interest I just turned 13
years old that week when the movie came
out looking back at that movie killing
out 1995 it's still fun and still can't
be Jim Carrey stole the whole movie as
the Riddler thank you Michael Lee of the
Michael Galvin Ali show so check out the
Michael Gavin Ali show and uh yeah I the
Batman Forever I was I think not quite
15 when that movie came out and that was
the movie I was pitting my hopes on this
summer walked in with a lot of
expectations I walked out as YouTube
blared and I was like I'm not sure what
I just saw Juan Harris you got fond
memories of Batman Forever I did not
like it when I saw it I I loved the
Burton version of Gotham I loved Batman
Returns I was hoping for more of that
and then it was this like colorful sort
of campy goofy more like the 60s show
and I was not into it but in in
subsequent years going back I now enjoy
it a lot and if you put yourself in a
different frame of mind it's a lot of
fun I love Nicole Kidman as Dr Chase
Meridian I think she's actually one of
the highlights of that whole movie and
those scenes with her and Val Kilmer are
like that's like the best Schumacher
Batman stuff I think uh I agree about
Tommy Lee Jones though it's it's all Jim
Carrey Tommy Lee Jones kind of doesn't
find his voice or he doesn't get
two-faced I don't think or doesn't care
so that feels famously doesn't enjoy Jim
Carrey's buffoonery
like you could kind of tell he's just
his heart's not into it it's it's not
one of his better sort of 90s turns but
he's like I just won an Oscar yeah I was
I was just the guy in The Fugitive now
what the hell am I doing Jacqueline are
we gonna have words about Batman Forever
or where do you find it actually what's
weird is Batman Forever is one of those
movies where if I could cherry pick
certain things about it it would be like
num num num num num and then other
things about it would make me nauseous
so I actually really enjoyed Val Kilmer
I think he actually does the Bruce Wayne
aloof billionaire as well as he's able
to do the the Batman stuff and he was
one of the few people that could be
believable in both of those little
aspects of it doesn't make him a great
Batman but I really enjoyed him and
poison ivy well not poison ivy yeah is
that poison ivy forever
no no Batman Forever is just Tommy Lee
Jones and the Riddler right yeah no Jim
Carrey is the one that that stole it in
that one yeah I remember being so bummed
that they didn't keep the Danny Elfman
score the there's like there's a couple
notes of it but it's not the cool Gotham
score that you want so I was like what
the hell are we doing here but that
YouTuber with anybody besides Tim Burton
and you're you're you keep mentioning
Colby thrilled me kiss me kill me a
great song this is also the the kiss
from this is Kiss From A Rose yes that
was the other thing I wanted to steal is
the soundtrack for this yeah the
soundtrack for this gave me what I
expected from The Prince album on the
first Batman which I didn't get yeah
there's a great two or three songs from
that Prince album on Batman party man is
great the rest of the album is very
there's a lot of Skips in that album but
the Batman Forever soundtrack all Bops
no skips man look at Michael just opened
up the floodgates here with our opinions
on Batman Forever that might have to be
a future episode thank you Michael
um so we're gonna say good night here
and I don't know that we solved the
Spaceballs conundrum I just hope that we
reminded critics out there who have not
yet reviewed Spaceballs that it needs
your help we need your positive reviews
I will tellathon for Spaceballs to get
into fresh territory Juan Harris it is
always a pleasure when you end your
comedic wit and your intelligent insight
into our silly little conversations uh
what are you working on where can all
the kids find you out there uh well
follow me on Twitter that's at l-o-n-s
that's the best place to keep up with
everything I'm doing of course I I write
honest trailers or I'm one of the
writers of honest trailers you can check
those out every week on screen junkies
on YouTube and uh check out my podcast
with Hal redneck we watch streaming
shows every week and then yell about
what we thought about them it's called
binge boys and you can find that on
Spotify uh yeah apple wherever you
listen to your podcasts binge boys a
little bit of a spoofy name just a just
a you know like a dash of yeah we are we
are in fact boys who binge but you know
we're having fun with it
oh like I said when you can email us RTS
wrong at rottentomatoes.com subscribe
rate review share do all that good stuff
well do you have any recommendations
since you are a binge boy
um that you maybe think all the kids out
there should be checking out right now
just generally like what's on TV right
now I've really been enjoying uh the old
man that FX Hulu series with Jeff
Bridges and John Lithgow great dogs it's
a lot good good dog stuff for that it's
very much like a conventional like you
know old retired operative got to come
out of hiding one last mission you know
back on the Run uh it's just it's so
good it's doing a really good job of
being that uh and John Watts who does
the the Spider-Man films directed the
first two episodes and really nailed it
looks looks great so have you checked
out the old man at all yeah Jacqueline
the old man is the yes Jeff Bridges I
saw the pilot yeah I saw the pilot
episode of that one and I haven't seen
past it because it was like that under
the banner Moon and then the the show
with Josh Brolin that came out of range
outer range all at the same time and
like I couldn't catch up on all of them
because right now I'm catching up on the
stuff for Emmys but the first episode
The Pilot was amazing also [ __ ] Spacek
and JK Simmons uh night sky night sky
like
I put all four of those and what I like
to call things I will watch to maybe
recommend to other people in my life who
I know will dig it the best my
Yellowstone friends as I like to say and
that that old man I heard is like
definitely one of those I recommend the
old man to all of your Yellowstone
loving friends that's what I'm like with
I fall asleep watching Yellowstone I
want to love it I just fall asleep every
episode but the old man I'm locked in in
my head cannon that John Lithgow is
playing the same role he did as the dad
and Harry and the Hendersons and he
called Jeff Bridges character to make
Harry disappear once and for all and
that is what they're trying to cover up
it depends up not being the plot this is
the first time those two have ever
worked together is that crazy it feels
like they should have been making movies
together but it does but if you really
think about it they both feel the same
role in a lot of things they're either
the guy or they're the guy that's
helping the girl and if they're not one
of those two characters they don't have
a reason to be in the movie together and
so you feel what I'm saying I do you're
right they're they're like a good like
the heavy you know like so if you
already have one heavy you don't need a
second heavy I agree too heavy did we
just see Franny pop in here with a wig
I'm so sorry I'm not letting that pass
by Lucy's daughter just popped in in a
wig a blue wig yep
there It Is Well it can only go downhill
from here so I guess we're gonna say
thank you and good night to all of our
incredible listeners we got a big big
episode next week Jacqueline tell the
kids about it yes folks can y'all count
this High because we are going this High
that's right ladies and gentlemen 100
episodes our 100 episode Special where
we're gonna talk about what you guys
have been saying what videos you've been
sending in very very very excited and
Juan's been a charter member of a few of
those episodes so thank you for his
service and we will continue to lean on
him to give us smart things he's gonna
say about movies and maybe stream maybe
we'll do the old man someday it should
be fun but after we get through Batman
forever obviously so uh yeah tomorrow
tomorrow next week's going to be a very
exciting time for us to coordinate 100
episodes that means you're doing
something right so in the meantime I'll
shut up and let us all start marinating
in that gory that's Jacqueline Coley my
co-host that's Lon Harris our steam
guest that is producy Lucy that is
producing Lucy's daughter with the blue
hair and Brian Perez who has thoughts on
Spaceballs that I'm glad we're not
shared during this episode sorry Brian I
am merely Mark Ellis thanks for
listening to Rotten Tomatoes is wrong
May the Schwartz be with you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you